what do you do when it just seems
impossible to go forward there's only
one thing you can do play it like a
[ __ ] breaking it we're gonna summon
Walter Walter Walter my main man hey
dude nice [ __ ] hat
oh yes the saw blade - that's awesome
Walter we're gonna pimp out alright
Voltaire remember the plan voltar you
take all the damage while I'll just look
back Walter you listening this is one of
the hardest bosses in the game
alright voltar let's do this alright
you've altered tank it camp I dodge I
died that's the first time I died Walter
he said can't [ __ ] see ah [ __ ]
hell this place is to sky voltar are you
doing anything at all mate Walter you're
sucking a lot of dick right now bolster
use your [ __ ] up use your [ __ ] heal
mate keep hitting in Boulder what the
[ __ ] is going on ah
Oh cheeky bastard both their [ __ ]
healing ah what the [ __ ] was that
Boulder let's do this voltar dodge to
first attack but that nailed it nailed
the first attack oh we crippled that
[ __ ] aim for his [ __ ]
Oh God Walter you might want to heal
mate both they're all thank God He
healed Jesus Christ that was close
what insta-kill vaulter this [ __ ]
boss it's ridiculous we had matching
outfits and everything mother F from
Naruto
you [ __ ] attacks ah yeah I know
what's going on
gotta watch out for that [ __ ]
insuk el esta cow and Sekou insta-kill
this account this account it's Kelly
it's been 84 yes how I guess a Chuck
it's a lot higher level now hahahaha
doing some pretty sick damage not gonna
lie we got this [ __ ] the [ __ ] is going
on
huh what what what
what hmm hmm he is so ugly oh my god
that's badass that's not even a CEO
[ __ ] horse with a sword Jesus Christ
guys guys teamwork hi I'm gonna shoot
him uh wait one second gotta show them
got that [ __ ] again yeah I've got that
[ __ ] I didn't even do that much damage
Jesus Christ ah keep hitting em guys oh
[ __ ] me [ __ ] your for killing Neruda
fans
[ __ ] you in general
that was the cheapest boss fight of all
time thank [ __ ] god what have you
seen shut that [ __ ] ah okay what do we
got in here okay this is the perfect
chance for me to a god I don't think I
want to fight those look at this [ __ ]
oh I love it it's the best thing this
weapon I love it so much
what is this whoa love what you've done
with the place
oh [ __ ] what's up [ __ ] you can't take a
compliment
oh yeah come in come in come in come
here come here come here come here
got your bench you're like a poop you
like Oreos you like Oreos [ __ ]
whoops punch you like punches BAM
they're going down you're going down
[ __ ]
never mind that looks very nice looks
like you're having a bad of fun a little
bit of Friday fun huh
hey hey I'm not hating
awesome awesome hey man you like Oreos
tell me do you like Oreos I'm a big fan
of Oreos I would love to know if you
like them - Oreos do you [ __ ] like
Oreos [ __ ] or AHA do your life
come back ah wonder what my neighbors is
thinking Oreos whoo
that guy's tough oh oh oh what what what
this must be a
this must be it yeah yeah yeah okay all
right Oh God
are you Maria you're a [ __ ] flower
living failures I can't relate that's
right show me that ass bad Joe you have
a great ass you're not a failure come on
come on baby
[ __ ]
that's right show me that ass
oh my god you're annoying
goddamn there tom [ __ ] you don't
insta-kill me Jesus Christ Jesus Christ
oh that looks badass a couple more of
these [ __ ]
oh no more [ __ ] or that [ __ ] [ __ ]
off give with your galaxy
No Oh God
will you have enough for the [ __ ]
meteors
ah
god [ __ ] you
oh nothing not today
[ __ ] [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate you
Oh
that's right bleach god damn they were
annoying [ __ ] sunflower lip oh god
damn it [ __ ] ass the view is nice
though oh damn this is another boss
fight right away oh my god are you
kidding me
was that just a warm-up or some [ __ ]
look at this are you lady Maria perhaps
she's dead I don't have to fight her
haha
whoopsie I know how I feel about that
hey [ __ ] Oh Oh God oh you can stomach
her ha ha ha oh you know with them Oh
God
stop please please you know what that
means
you like Oreos
I swear you love them don't you Marc
Marc Marc Marc now Oh [ __ ]
okay here we go you want some [ __ ]
[ __ ] up your [ __ ] Oh God let me
reload [ __ ] me [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I was
reloading swear to God I was reeling
give me a break okay thanks for that
Jesus Christ calm down lady okay no I'm
glad you heard me
I'm alive I don't know how the [ __ ] I'm
alive from that here ah [ __ ] you in that
attack I'm alive again Oh pure panic
[ __ ] I should have done that if I just
stayed cool I could have totally done it
[ __ ] oh man I get all shaky [ __ ] hell
Oh
oh whoa oh that was so close oh that was
such a [ __ ] exciting fight [ __ ]
hell I just came oh my god I'm sweating
I'm shaking
all right I'll end this episode here
thank you so much for supporting this
series and leaving a like I really
really appreciate it thank you so much
and as always stay awesome hey Gramps
hey Graham wake up drop goddamnit
Graham's always drinks too much ah